let's talk about this podcast mama knows
best
what has it been like working together
sort of in this
capacity and i imagine learning new
things about
one another it's been interesting to say
the least i think
it's way different than i thought it
would be
i feel like a lot of people would see us
and like have their own interpretation
of like our relationship and like kind
of just things we've been through or
done and like now it's like a more
in-depth version of that so it's like
the true real raw
version of kind of topics that we talk
about and um
life experiences we've had and it's been
really fun being able to do with my mom
because
if anyone knows me for who i am and like
growing up it was her so
have you guys learned anything about one
another
in doing this i feel like
yeah like learned how to get on each
other's nerves more
definitely that she was already a pro at
it
so it's only helping her yeah better
so much better but yeah i mean i've
learned like small funny things like
just recently we talked about like
childhood crushes and and things like
that are there any topics that are
harder to discuss just because it is a
mother-daughter
conversation i feel like sometimes it
can be
a little weird or like uncomfortable but
i feel like at the end of the day it's
just a conversation and it's just kind
of like giving ourselves the chance to
be vulnerable and like for me it's the
more like
things that i don't want to talk about
are like
boys or whatever but like on mom knows
best like i've definitely opened up to
her
and like the audience especially about
kind of like my thoughts and
relationships and my relationship
experience and just things i've
um gone through emotionally and like
figured out about myself
so i feel like it kind of just gave me a
chance to be vulnerable about it and
like really open
up versus kind of covering it or like
you know hiding it it just gave me a
chance to open up and especially when we
record it it's just us too so it's like
very organic sherry what about for you
are there any topics that are hard
even as her mom to sort of dive into or
dissect at all
maybe maybe a little about about the
relationship
things that's that's kind of difficult i
guess
to share for each of us it would be kind
of
difficult because of my relationships
and hers and
you know just being a teenager and some
things that she
never really wanted to share with me but
now it's coming out
she's sharing more with me is there uh
a dream guest or mother-daughter duo
that you would love to have
on the podcast reese witherspoon and her
daughter ava that would be really cool
yeah she i feel like that would just be
like a really fun one especially because
i just haven't met reese and like she's
just
a really great actress and i love big
little lies i feel like that just makes
me want to talk to her even more
and i feel like she's quite the
tick-tocker lately yeah
for sure so i feel like hey it makes
sense yeah
what about courtney and chris would you
want them on the show have you talked to
them about this
i would totally love to have them on the
show i think it would be hilarious
um i love courtney and chris so much so
i'm sure it'd be really interesting to
kind of compare like their relationship
to ours and
um see things but who knows in the
future what that holds
when i first met you i mean we kind of
talked about this but you were just
blowing up we were at the hype house
with you
what has it been like to sort of reach
this new level
of stardom and what's been i guess the
best part and what's been the hardest
part
for you i think the best part has just
been the people that i've met and the
connections i've made
the friendships that i have now and like
are continuing to
to get are like such deep
and fun and loving relationships because
i think everyone
that i've met has kind of just had the
same mindset and same goals and it's
super easy to relate to them and
i think the hardest part would probably
be
like just i guess the negativity i feel
like that's a pretty common answer but
i think just dealing with you know the
fact that there are just going to be
people that don't like you
and will always have something negative
to say about you and i think
a big part of that too was just kind of
dealing with like
the pressures of being um so
talked about on the internet at a time
that's been the hardest part but
there's so many good parts about this
industry and the social media world that
like
it kind of just outweighs it and at the
end of the day i have to look at the
positive and not
look at the negative the positive has
brought me so many great things
i love how positive you are and i feel
like through this you've managed to keep
a very good solid head on your shoulders
what is the secret to that and how will
you continue to do that
i think it's just taking a step back
every once in a while
and really um looking at it from a
different perspective really just
looking where you came from and for me
that's
my family they're here they're
supporting me they love me and like i've
done
so many great things in such a short
amount of time and
i think it's just always about that like
stepping back appreciating everything
that you have
and everything that you receive and um
and really just
thanking everyone around you and
appreciating them in their time too
sherry is there anything that you want
to add to that i just always want her to
be grateful and thankful
that's very important to me yeah i think
too
resilience is a big one for me being
able to bounce back
always just remembering that there is a
brighter side to everything and that you
can always get there
it's just sometimes you have to go
through the hard times to get to the
good times
let's talk about something super fun and
that's the walk challenge
now from the top make a job
[Music]
i just want your honest reaction to your
mom doing it because i was very
impressed
i was impressed too i could never have
imagined
in my entire life actually that i would
watch my mom do anything similar to that
never thought i would see that nor did i
think i ever wanted to see that
but i want to say it was entertaining
and you kind of
did a great job mom so i'm proud of you
what was it like to see
cardi's response to your guys's what
challenges it was so cool i thought it
was so funny and
i'm glad she enjoyed watching it as much
as i enjoyed watching hers too but
i thought it was so cool and amazing
yeah it was really fun
tick tock i mean you are the highest
paid person
on the platform when you heard that news
i mean were you
shocked were you in denial were you
excited like how did that
feel it is pretty crazy i mean all of
that
is is really crazy and i feel like it's
just i feel like it's all just such a
broad
conversation though you know it's like
at the end of the day like we're all
just having so much fun that we're not
even focused on that like that's not one
of our main like
oh my gosh i'm making this or i'm doing
this or i mean it's really just us
enjoying our time and like really taking
in our opportunities both of you guys
have incredible platforms on there
do you think there's a chance tick tock
goes away on september
15th i didn't even know that
there's a day there's a date i did not
know that
um i don't know okay now that you say
that
i didn't know that but i will say that
if it is
safety concerns there's really nothing
you know to say back about that besides
the fact that if it's keeping us safe
and it's something about that then
it makes sense but it would be a really
really sad day because that's where we
started and we're broke and we love tick
tock so much but
at the end of the day if it's for safety
we will continue working on our other
projects
what does the addison ray empire look
like
yeah it's really just a little bit of
everything you know
i have you know my merch with fan joy
and then i have my podcast my
makeup line and then working on a lot of
other exciting things coming up and
i think it's all just a part of the the
bigger picture and kind of just building
this
frame to who i am apart from the merch i
feel like you're such
a fashionista is a clothing line
something that you would think about um
yeah so
people could definitely argue that and
say that my fashion sense is not the
greatest on tick tock because i
definitely i i do i love fashion so much
i think for my
tick tock sometimes i'm kind of random
but i think for me i
love doing things that almost like make
people uncomfortable in a sense like
like like what is she wearing or like
what i don't get it you know and then
i feel like just testing like different
waters in fashion is always so much fun
and kind of just
discovering new things and trying things
out and i mean they don't always work
don't get me wrong
but i think yeah it would definitely be
super fun a super fun conversation to
have about fashion and
hopefully one day having something of my
own or even with my mom or my family and
um yeah continuing to expand our brand
is acting something that you're still
interested in yeah i love to act i've
done
lots of classes i've read tons of
scripts you know just
done things that you do to prepare for
that and i think it's always a really
exciting conversation and
a long and very hard journey but
it's always worth it in the end so
hopefully that'll continue to be a part
of my life and
maybe something big will come out of it